former white house press secretary and
fox news contributor sarah sanders joins
me now she is the author of the new book
speaking for myself faith freedom and
the fight of our lives
inside the trump white house sarah
always great to talk with you
you and i were together now it's day two
since this bob woodward information has
come out
and a lot of questions about how things
might have been done differently i first
want to ask you
what's your take on what the chief of
staff mark meadows is saying now that he
would have suggested to the president
he not do this i mean after all bob
woodward had already written some stuff
that was not positive about the
president
look i don't think the chief of staff is
necessarily wrong but honestly harris i
don't care what bob woodward has to say
to me he's just another liberal media
mogul out there trying to take the
president down i think
every time he writes a book he writes it
for one purpose he wants to sell
books so he's looking for the most
negative light he can to portray this
president
and frankly i don't have to read his
book because i spent two and a half
years
serving alongside the president i know
who he is
i know that he loves this country and i
know that he is constantly fighting
for the country and the people to defeat
the liberal mob that is out to destroy
us it's the reason frankly that i
wanted to write the book that i did
speaking for myself because i want
people to know the real story
and see the real truth behind who donald
trump is and how much he loves this
country and all of the things that he's
doing to help
keep our country great and move us
forward
yeah and not to miss it sarah your book
is hitting at a critical time
as well and you're able to put that
message out there too
and we're going to pop it up on the
screen as we go to this
carl bernstein who broke the watergate
scandal with bob woodward says
trump committed a kind of homicidal
negligence
by downplaying the pandemic and he
claims the audio recordings are even
more devastating than the nixon tapes
but he didn't stop there watch
we listen to him cover up this grave
national emergency
this is one of the great presidential
felonies
of all time maybe the greatest
presidential felony and we have the
smoking gun tape
of the president committing the felony
sarah i can almost see you still
standing behind that lectern and
what would you say at a white house
press briefing to that
well i think his comments are ridiculous
the president didn't want people to
panic
he didn't want our economy to collapse
if anybody is guilty of not paying
attention to the pandemic it's democrats
who were so
focused on impeachment and attacking the
president
while he was actually taking action like
stopping travel from china
and mobilizing our communities to
provide resources
and ppe gear and ventilators and other
things that hospitals and
our first responders needed the
president took action while democrats
were busy trying to destroy him
i think if bernstein wants to take some
comments uh
on who was negligent i think he has
another group of people he should focus
his fire on
you know what is so fascinating and i i
wonder if our viewers actually caught
that
um you didn't go for the person who was
not in office joe biden with your
comments just right then
you talked specifically about people who
were focused on impeachment who had the
responsibility and the jobs to have
maybe done something
uh regarding the pandemic that is
fascinating um i i want to ask you also
about the messaging going forward john
roberts just reported sarah that we
could see a few more days of this maybe
not atop the headlines but the book
hasn't come out yet from bob woodward
that's next week and then you'll see the
follow-up so on and so forth
what message do you think should be
coming from the white house and the
president
right now well i think they should keep
their focus where it needs to be
it needs to be exactly what the
president said
law in order we have to talk about
making our community safe
we have to talk about moving our country
forward he needs to keep
our focus on safety security and
prosperity
because at the end of the day that's
what the people care about
they want to know that they can walk
down the street and not be attacked they
want to know that they can go in and out
of a business
they want to know that they can drop
their kids off and they're going to get
a good education
and that they'll have a job to go to
once they drop them off
that's what the american people care
about that's what the president should
be focused on
he has a great record of almost four
years of accomplishments
he should be talking about the substance
of what he's done in those four years
and what he'll continue to do once
reelected in november
sarah sanders her new book is out pick
it up always great to see you thank you
very much
thank you harris always great to be with
you as well